now in a u-turn from last year's
decision to defund the police
minneapolis
now plans to spend big on law
enforcement to tackle
a spike in violent crime the city
council says it will inject 6 million
dollars
well recent data does suggest that the
number of gunshot victims is up 250
compared to the same period last year at
the same time rape cases have increased
22 percent
and robbery by almost 60 percent the
city currently has around 200 fewer
officers than usual
and that's after many left the force or
went on leave following the death of
george floyd
in may last year
[Applause]
[Music]
but we're not gonna stop we're gonna
keep protesting we're gonna keep going
i want i want change bro we all want to
change
this is what you get when you don't hold
other cops accountable
when you let them kill other people when
you let them kill us
when you don't hold your partner
accountable this is it this is it
following the protest the president of
the minneapolis city council announced
plans to replace the police with what
she called
a transformative new model of public
safety
and she wasn't the only one calling for
such radical changes
i will never co-sign on funding a police
department that continues to brutalize
us
and i will never stop saying not only do
we need to disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department
[Applause]
remember they voted a few months ago to
take
uh eight million dollars away from the
police department which they did
and what happened there there are some
businesses in the city of minneapolis
who are getting robbed by the same
person
two and three times in a week and now
for the city council
to say well we're going to spend money
to hire new police officers
so you know you almost you almost have
to
laugh at it it's ridiculous what's going
to happen is you are going to see
a shortage of police officers in larger
urban
centers like minneapolis new york
chicago
los angeles most if not all of these
cities
are run by the democrats and the
democrats tend to not
support their police officers you can't
support your criminals
and consider them victims and not
support your police and not expect
crime to rise and in all those cities i
mentioned
most of them have skyrocketing homicide
rates skyrocketing violent crime rates
you vilify your police officers you
better make friends with criminals
because that's all you're going to have
left
you